foreign
's YouTube channel in this session we
will learn how to find the second
highest salary in a SQL table but before
we begin let me tell you guys that we
have daily updates on multiple
Technologies if you're a tech geek in a
continuous hunt the latest technological
Trends then consider getting subscribed
to our YouTube channel and don't forget
to hit that Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn now without
further Ado let's get started with the
one point agenda that is how to find the
second highest salary in SQL so this
particular type of questions will be
most frequently Asked in data analytics
interview questions so let's try to
understand the syntax of how to find the
not just second but any number of
salaries given in a SQL table let's say
your interviewer asked you to find the
top third salary or top fourth salary
you can find that using the same syntax
so the syntax is something similar to
this as shown now but before we begin if
you are an aspiring data analyst then I
have the perfect cause for you we have
the professional certificate program in
data analytics boast your career over
this data analytics program in
partnership with Purdue University and
in collaboration with IBM which features
master classes and follows an applied
learning model with real-time projects
and business case studies now that we
have a clear understanding of the pgp
data analytics certification with simply
learn in collaboration with IBM from
Purdue University we will get started
with our tutorial for today's session
so here you can see select star you can
also use these specific columns you want
that is name and salary but I'm
selecting star that is every single
column in my table that is Select Staff
from employee table Group by salary so
you'll be grouping by salary here and
order by salary descending since we
wanted to find the highest we will be
choosing the descending order that is
increased number that is the highest
number to the lowest number in case if
your employer or if your interviewer
asks you to find the lowest salary then
you will be using the ascending order
right so since we are given the
condition that we have to find the
highest we will use the descending order
then limit n minus 1 let's say You're
supposed to find the fifth highest
salary then the formula will be 5 minus
1 and the limit one that is you just
want one single row to be displayed on
your output right so that's the reason
we'll be giving limit as one right so
this is the simple syntax you will be
following now let's quickly execute this
on MySQL workbench and try to get our
results
back to the Microsoft SQL workbench so
now we are on the MySQL workbench let's
quickly use the database and get access
to our all tables now we have access to
the tables and the employee table which
we were working on
so let's quickly have the show tables
here and
we have employee and employee table 2 we
will be accessing the employee table
which has the salary details so there
you go we have Rakesh Jack Regina Etc
right so here you can see Karen has the
highest salary and the next second
highest salary is Rakesh so we need to
fetch this particular column here right
since our expectation is to find the
second highest salary let's try to
write the following code that is Select
star from employee
Group by
salary
earned by salary
descending order since we want highest
salary and the limit
n minus 1 that is 2 minus 1 or you can
also write as 1 comma 1. and done
let's quickly execute this code and
there you go now let's say we want to
find the third highest salary so here n
minus 1 3 minus 1 is 2
and execute this
and there you go you have Regina so
that's how you can extract second
highest salary or any number of highest
salary or the lowest salary based on the
query changes you're doing let's say if
you want the highest salary then you
should be using descending order let's
say you want the lowest salary should be
using the ascending order so that's how
you can extract the second highest
salary from SQL tables and with that we
have come to an end of this session and
if you have any queries or if you
require the resources that we used in
the session maybe the sample codes
syntax or the PPT then do let us know in
our team of experts will be more than
happy to resolve all your queries are
the earliest until next time thank you
stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
foreign